Hello, my name is Harrison Lee.
I'm a professional competitive viewer and three time Canadian national yo-yo
champion. Today.
I've been challenged to demonstrate yo-yo tricks in 26 levels of increasing
complexity.
Today, we'll be focusing on yo-yo tricks using an unresponsive yo-yo.
That means we'll not be going into tricks that use multiple yo-yos or yo-yos
echo off the string. This is an endless journey into yo-yoing yo-yo tricks,
continuously evolve and transform.
It's very similar to a hip hop dance where dancers will start with some
fundamentals and then build up into their own combinations.
This is my interpretation of the challenge.
Complexity is defined as additional movements,
additional elements that are combined in these tricks and layers and precision
and control required. So there are two main different categories of viewing.
There's a response of your use and unresponsive you use for the first few
levels.
We're going to start with a responsive view level one downward sleeper.
So the downward sleeper is the first trick that everybody learns when they start
to you. It's a simple list trick, and it involves throwing the yo-yo down,
letting it spin for a bit at the very end or sleep,
and then bringing it back up. So to begin this trick,
you start with your arm based out and a muscle formation,
and then you extend your arm and then flick your wrist. At the very end.
The flick of the wrist at the very end is super,
super important because that's what allows it to give the yo-yo the most spin.
So it's very similar to, you know, tennis or badminton,
right at the very end when you hit and flick your wrist,
that's where you get the most power. If you don't do that,
the yo-yo doesn't have enough spin other than unfortunately,
it'll spin out and die at the end. Um,
and you're sad moving into the next level.
We'll be building off of the downward sleeper and adding an additional element
that will propel the yo-yo forward level to walk the dog
super common trick.
It's the first trick that people will ask you to do when they know that you can
go, you walk, the dog begins by throwing the yo-yo down in a downward sleeper.
You then rest of the yo-yo on the floor, forcing it to propel forward,
or you walk the dog. And then at the very end,
you give it a little tug and the yo-yo returns to you.
When you're trying to walk the dog for the first time,
sometimes you might not have enough spin on the yo-yo.
So when it hits the floor,
the yo-yo will immediately start spinning because of the additional amount of
friction.
So a lot of professional users will avoid this strict simply because how
expensive these yo-yos can cost.
And so when somebody asks you to do walk the dog with your $500 titanium yo-yo
you were as cringed for a bit and think,
do I really want to damage the weight distribution and may you and mess it all
up, going into the next level.
We're going to be adding a few additional elements to make the tricks a lot more
showy, level three around the world,
around the world starts in a forward pass.
And then instead of it returning to you, the yo-yo returning to you,
you do a full rotation,
or you let the yo-yo move around the world and you rotate the OU with your hand,
almost like you're swinging it in the spiral motion.
And then you return the glue back to your hand.
When you're doing around the world,
it's important that you follow through with your revolution. If you don't,
you have the chance of hitting yourself in the head,
we're going to be introducing amount to the next level,
which will increase the complexity and the number of moving parts going on level
four, rock the baby. So right, the baby,
like the name suggests and involves creating a cradle Mount and then rocking the
U U back multiple times, generally a solid rock.
The baby involves three full swings,
and then you drop the yo-yo or you drop the baby out of the Mount,
and then you bring the yo-yo back up.
And it's important that you stop between rocks,
that you're not moving the yo-yo back and forth too quickly so that you remain
in control.
And the next level things get a little bit more complex because we're going to
let the yo-yo leave our hand level five skyrocket
the sky rocket begins in a downward through you,
let the yo-yo sleep at the very end.
And then you let the yo-yo string and the Slipknot off your hand and throw the
yo-yo up in the air as a yo-yo is midway in the air. It rules back up,
and then as, as it's falling down, you catch it in your hands.
So when you're learning skyrocket for the first time,
it's really important that after you let you go off your hand and throw it up in
the air, you have your eye on the prize, ready to catch it.
If you don't do that, unfortunately,
the yo-yo will fall on the floor and you'll dent your $500 titanium. Yo-yo.
Now that things are getting a little bit more complex,
it's time to switch to an unresponsive view.
So the unresponsive yo-yo is going to be harder because you can't bring an
unresponsive view back up. You have to purposefully not the yoyo,
which will be doubling into the next level.
Level six bind is how you return an unresponsive
view. So it's a matter of purposefully nodding, the yo-yo,
which contacts the friction surface on either side,
forcing the yo-yo to come back up.
This is the first unresponsive yo-yo trick that people learn,
because you need to learn how to bring the yo-yo back up. Otherwise,
you're going to spend a lot of time winding it back up manually.
So you begin in a downward sleeper, like our first strict that we learned,
but instead of taking the yo-yo back up,
you rest your index finger on the front of the yo-yo string.
You wrap around,
you hit the yo-yo and then cross the strings and then give it a little tug to
bring it back up. When you give it a little tug,
you'll have a loop of string that will fall into the gap of the yo-yo.
This will contact the friction surface, causing the OU to spin back up.
So the most important thing to remember is control, and to also have a really,
really good through, because if you don't throw the yo-yo hard enough,
it won't spin for a long enough time at the very end.
And you'll not have enough time to wrap the yo-yo string around it to bring it
back up. So in a nurse, once a viewing,
there are three main styles of yo-yo tricks.
So you have your front style through,
which is where you're throwing the yo-yo down right in front of you.
You have your side style through,
which is where you're throwing the you're off to the side.
And then finally a horizontally through where the yo-yo spins off.
All the tricks that we seen in the past six levels have used a Ford through the
next we'll be using a side style through level seven trapeze.
So the trap B starts in a breakaway through,
instead of throwing the yo-yo in front of you,
you make a muscle formation off to the side, you extend your arm,
flick your wrist, just the same and you land on a trapeze.
So the yo-yo in this case is the man and the string is a trapeze.
So as the yo-yo is coming through through that breakaway,
you flick the yo-yo onto your index string,
and it lands in a formation or a Mount called the trapeze as the yo-yo is coming
through.
It's important that you land the yo-yo on the trapeze when beginners are
learning in this trick, the yo-yo will fall off.
And so you kill the man on the trapeze lovable eight brain twister.
So the brain twister is a super impressive trick,
especially when you're starting to learn how to yo-yo and involves throwing the
yo-yo down in a downward sleeper, right in front of you.
And very similar to the bind where you go in front of the yo-yo this time you'll
want to go behind.
And so you Mount the yo-yo from behind and you have one longer string and
statement one shorter string segment, and he pushed the oo into you.
You force the yo-yo to rotate,
and you want to do that three times very similar to rocking the baby.
You let the string, same it go, and then bring the yo-yo back up.
So the next level things are going to get a little bit more complex because
we're going to be combining two tricks that we've seen before the trap peas and
the brain twister level nine skin, the juror bowl. So skin,
the dribble funny name begins in a trapeze,
and then you double Mount the trapeze on.
So there's two loops around your index finger on your non through hand,
you unloop the yo-yo and then you Mount the yo-yo on your opposite index finger.
You unmount, you do a brain twister like motion, you dismount from the trapeze,
and then you bring in the, you,
you backup for this trick in particular control is especially important.
You want to make sure that you're landing the OU on the string and dismounting
it correctly.
Sometimes you make Bumble and the yo-yo might not land on the string correctly.
And so that precision is super important because the yo-yo tricky is longer as
well. It's important that you have a really good spin at the start.
Otherwise the yo-yo may die or start spitting midway through.
So now we're moving onto the next level,
which could be considered our first mini combo level 10,
Mach five Sumach five. It begins in a florid through,
and you start in a split bottom Mount,
you do a barrel rule and then isolate the yo-yo in the center of the string.
And you rotate your index fingers around the yo-yo.
So it looks like the yo-yo is stationary while you're moving around it.
And it's very similar to, you know, contact juggling,
where the object is staying in one position, and you're manipulating around it.
After you do three full rotations or three Mach five revolutions,
you dismount and you bring the yo-yo back backup by doing a simple bind
districts requires a lot,
a lot of control to keep the yo-yo in that single space.
As you're rotating around it, you don't want to rotate too quickly,
but you also don't want to rotate slowly because you're putting so much pressure
on the yo-yo to maintain it in one space,
the yo-yo may spin off access and gyrus group.
The key to maintaining that control is by pulling your index fingers away from
the yo-yo so that it forces it to stay in that one position.
And then when you're doing your rotations,
you want to rotate at a constant motion.
So that Dao doesn't start spinning midway through.
The next trick is going to involve a hop element,
which is unlike any other trick that we see seen so far today, level 11,
Eli hop,
the ELA hop starts in a breakaway through you Mount the yo-yo in a trapeze.
And then by bringing your hands together really quickly,
the yo-yo Springs up and launches off to the side.
You then land the yo-yo back on the trapeze. And that performs one, Eli hop.
The Eli hop is super impressive because it's so unexpected.
The yo-yo is stationary and a trapeze,
and then suddenly it Springs off to the side and hops out,
and then you land it back on the trapeze.
So it's very unpredictable and there's so many different variations of the trip
to where you can do some Eli hops, which are much larger and amplitude.
Some which are much smaller.
And you can combine various Eli hops together to create a combo leveled 12.
[inaudible] like the ones that we've seen before with the mock-ups,
the boogie boogie begins and a downward through.
And then you Mount the yo-yo and the 1.5 Mount, you do a single barrel roll.
And then you have the yo-yo between your two index fingers and you pop the yo-yo
back and forth between each string, say mint causing it to burn.
You're going back and forth. You want to do that a handful of times,
you then dismount the yo-yo and you return it with a bind when learning a boy
for the first time, it's really easy for the yo-yo to fall off the string,
mid boy, you're doing your Boonie boiling,
and then the yo-yo will pop up the string and then you have to restart.
So it's important that you have that control the bounce of yo-yo back and forth
between those two strings.
And you have a clear eye on where the yo-yo is at every given motion.
So the additional complexity that we'll be introducing in the next trick, yeah.
Involves a Slack element level 13 revolutions revolutions is a
repeater. A repeater that we've seen before was the Mach five.
And very similarly at the Eli hop or the rock, the baby,
were you doing a moment repetitively, but with the revolutions,
you're manipulating a Slack element. So you begin in a split bottom Mount.
And when you're in that split bottom Mount,
you pinch the string with your index finger and your thumb causing the yo-yo
string to Slack.
You then rotate the yo-yo string inwards and outwards from your hand causing the
yo-yo string to fold the, you, as you spin to do the air,
it's almost like waving a fan after you've repeated it. A handful of times,
you dismount from the Mount and you bring the video back up with the revolution,
very similar to the Mach five.
It's really important that you maintain your momentum as you're doing each of
those revolutions,
have you started spinning the yo-yo midway through the yo-yo Slack formation
will break, and then you'll have to repeat it again.
Level 14 Brent store.
So the Bryn stall involves a new kind of element called the laceration.
So with the laceration,
you pop the yo-yo up into the air and he create a Slack movement underneath the
yo-yo and create a formation so that when the yo-yo falls back onto the string,
it falls into that formation or into that Mount.
So with the Brent stall in particular,
the yo-yo falls into a triangle like formation or triangle like Mount.
One of the common mistakes when players learn Brent stole for the first time is
not slacking the yo-yo underneath the string enough to create a large enough
loop to create that triangle formation, the yo-yo to land back onto the string.
So the next level is also a repeater and it involves the Slack element.
And you rotate around your non index through hand and level of 15
Yuki Slack.
So you begin in an F side style through and start in a trapeze.
You then pinch your index finger and your thumb of your non through head of the
string by rotating it with a clockwise motion and capsule string,
same in a double or nothing,
even dismount from that double or nothing off to the side,
hit the yo-yo on the bottom of the string and Slack.
The yo-yo in the opposite direction.
You catch a string semen as it's going around,
and then you repeat the motion again. So you dismount,
you hop onto the string on your trapeze and he slapped it over into a double or
nothing back and forth, back and forth.
After you've done your fair share of Yuki slacks,
you dismount and you bring you back up.
So when difficulty with the Yuki Slack is that the trick can fall apart on
success of repeats. As you're slacking the yo-yo back and forth, back and forth.
It's really easy for the string and the yo-yo to get tangled up and resulting in
a dead yo-yo and a non in your hands level 16 black ops
black hops requires a lot of precision and a lot of control.
You begin in a triple or nothing Mount,
which is very similar to the double or nothing,
but you rotate the yo-yo around the string one more time.
So that there's three strings St. Mints on either index finger.
When you're in that triple or nothing,
you then bounce you off the string consecutively until you reach a trapeze.
So you're constantly bouncing the area back up, landing on the string,
bouncing dealio, back up, letting it on the string.
And then you land in that trap. Ease. Once you're out in the trapeze,
you want to build back up to a triple or nothing.
So you hop the yo-yo back up slash two off to the side at land,
in a truckies, and his brother jumped the yo-yo back up,
it lands in a double or nothing,
and you continue and totally you're in a triple or nothing.
Once you're in that triple or nothing. Again,
you drop all the string statements. So it's just resting on your index finger,
you dismount, and you do it by and to bring the AAO back up.
So with black-ops precision and control are your best friend.
You really want to make sure that you have an eye on the yo-yo as it's hopping
between the strings and you're landing on each string, same mint,
clearly when you're going down to the trapeze and when you're moving back up,
very similarly, you're landing on each string. Same minute clearly.
So the next trick we're going to make the yo-yo look like it's skipping rope
level 17 follows the trick, begins in a trapeze,
like many other tricks.
And you dismount you then slash are you with a karate chop,
like motion that creates a loop around your through hand,
and then you rotate it around the yoga multiple times,
kind of like skipping rope after you're done rotating around the yo-yo a handful
of times you land the yo-yo in iron whip,
which is where the yo-yo trick originated from.
And then you bring the yo-yo back up through a bind, like the Yuki Slack,
like the revolution, like the Mach five, the follows is a repeater.
What this trick momentum is super, super important. After you start the trick,
you have to keep following through otherwise the yo-yo and the string and the
Slack will get tangled up for the next trick.
We're going to be incorporating another part of our body.
And the yo-yo is skin aligned behind our back level,
18 leg wrap trap.
So the Lake rap trap begins in a brick way through you do a handful of around
the world, and then you step over the string with your right leg,
and then shortly after with your left leg.
And then afterwards you land in a trapeze behind your back,
you quickly dismount and bring the yo-yo back up to your hand.
So this yo-yo trick is also commonly known as the ball breaker because the
yo-yo string is going between your legs and can break your bowls.
Lots of mistakes to be made with the stricken.
The next trick is another laceration and involves wrapping the yo-yo string
around the yo-yo and nut time.
So you land in a 2.5 minutes level,
19 2.5 hook.
So the 2.5 hook like the triangle laceration involves popping the yo-yo up and
spinning you your string around the yo-yo multiple times to land the yo-yo back
into a Mount when it falls back down. And this case it's a 2.5 Mount,
which is like the one and a half mounds,
but with two and a half strings wrapped around the yo-yo instead.
So the yo-yo begins in a brick way through you pop the yo-yo up as the yo-yo is
midway through the air.
You take your two index fingers and you're wrapping around the string multiple
times,
two and a half times be exact as the yo-yo is falling back into the string.
You land in that 2.5 mountains. So this trick is really challenging,
cause it's quite risky. You either get it or you don't.
You have to try multiple times and it can be quite tiring to pop the yo-yo back
up, spin around with your index fingers and then land back onto the string.
So with the strict, because you're rotating around the UL multiple times,
it's common to not catch the string when it lands in the two plate five Mount.
So up to this point,
we've looked at the front style through and the breakaway through,
but we'll be introducing a new throw in this upcoming trick,
the horses or through level 20 banana turnover and horizontal pinwheel.
So the banana turnover and the horizontal pin wheel are two sides of the same
coin. They're just different based off of the way that you begin with the throw.
So in the case of the banana turnover, and it's more of a side silo throw,
but horizontal and with the horizontal pinwheel,
it's like a downward forward facing through, but horizontal.
So beginning with banana turnover, you begin an aside style through,
but instead horizontal. So kind of like you're throwing a Frisbee.
And then as the yo-yo is going around,
almost like you're about to hit in the trapeze.
You stick out your thumb facing downwards of your non through hand,
and the yoyo will wrap around your thumb, causing it to rotate.
You do that a couple of times,
and that rebalances the plane of the yo-yo so that you can land it in a trapeze.
After you're in that trapeze, you can do a variety of different tricks.
Ben and turnover is a starting point to many horizontal tricks.
And then you bring it back up with the horizontal Penwell you're throwing the
yo-yo across your body.
And as the yo-yo is fully extended at the end of the string,
you're doing a series of pinwheels to keep it in the same plane,
very similar to the banana turnover. After that,
you can transition into a horizontal combo and then bring the yo-yo up with a
bind.
Horizontal tricks are a lot more challenging than your typical sod style or
front style throw because you have to keep the yo-yo spinning.
Otherwise it'll spin out a plane level 21,
the UFO is a horizontal trick and he began by doing a banana turnover
as a yo-yo spinning around your thumb. You let it rest for a second,
almost allowing it to spin out and spin out of control.
But before it starts spinning, you popped the yo-yo up and you catch the,
are you returning it in a bind?
And it's called the UFO because it looks like a UFO is about to land.
The yo-yo is flat when you're performing the trick flat on the horizontal
plane and the yo-yo string spirals around it, because it's about to die.
You know,
you've done the strict correctly because the yo-yo will look like it's hovering
midway through the air. So the UFO is all about timing and it's about timing.
The amount of spin left in the yo-yo before you return it,
but you also wanted to let it spin out for a couple of rotations so that you can
get that cool hovering effect in that process. The yo-yo may spin out.
I control the humid day in between where you may not catch the
you as you pop it up. We're at a really advanced level now.
And for the next trick,
we're going to add a little bit of complexity by involving our neck level 22,
the Zack Gorham lead neck trick and involves starting human trapeze,
dismounting, bringing the yo-yo string above your head and above your neck,
wrapping the shrinks.
So it lands in a chopstick with your index finger and your thumb of your throw
hand pulling apart, almost like you're doing a revolution,
extending the yo-yo above and over your head crunching down so that the Slack
follows you dismounting and bringing the yo-yo back-up.
So this trick involves a lot of the levels that we've seen before,
including the trap PS, the revolution and the Slack.
So with Zack grumbly and metric, at one point,
you're not able to see the yo-yo because it's above your head.
So you need to make sure that you're extending far enough over so you don't
accidentally hit yourself.
So the next trick is the last of our non combo tricks and involves
spinning the yo-yo on your finger level 23 finger spin
Sidewinder.
So the finger spin Sidewinder begins and a horizontal pin wheel through after
you pinwheel a handful of times,
you pop the yo-yo up and land on your index finger of your non throw
hand. Oh, spin there for a couple of moments.
And after the U is about to dive very similar to the UFO.
You lacerate into the center of the string,
causing the yo-yo to bind as the O is binding you hover your throw hand on
top of the yo-yo causing the yo-yo to do a Sidewinder movement,
causing you to return back to your hand.
It's really important that you keep in mind the timing, very similar to the UFO.
When you landed on your finger,
the audio will spin out really quickly because of the additional amount of
friction. And initially, after you returned the yo-yo back up to your hand,
it'll mess up the string tension.
So the Slack and the string will be all in place.
So it'll be really difficult to do subsequent tricks.
If you decide to do a finger spin and Sidewinder during the middle of a routine.
So the next couple of tricks are combinations that I've created myself level
24, the Eli hop combo.
So in a competition, you, yours will often perform an Eli hop combo.
So an Eli hub combo involves the trick that we saw before the ELA hop.
It's a matter of doing different variations of that same trick in different
directions, in different sizes, in different planes.
So my take on the Eli hot Pombo begins and the reverse Brent stool,
I popped the yo-yo off to the side, my right hand side.
I then pop it in the opposite direction to the left-hand side of my body.
I then do a series of pop elements and then the yo-yo and a reverse
hook.
I then do reverse behind the elbow double or nothing.
I dismount very similar to a black hop.
I land the yo-yo string inverted in an inverted trapeze.
And then I return the yo-yo back to my hand.
So this Eli hop combo is something that I've been working on from 2017.
And I've been continuously adding new elements and new tricks as I've learned
that level 25 neck behind the back leg.
Okay?
So the neck behind the back leg combo involves three body parts, your neck,
your leg, of course, and then doing tricks behind your back.
So you start in a Yuki Slack like movement. And as a result,
you go around your neck,
wrapping around your neck and when you unravel your unravel.
So the yo-yo is landing behind your back. When the yo-yo is behind your back,
you do a pop like motion returning you back to a trapeze in front of your
body, invert yo-yo string.
And you go underneath your non through hand leg.
So it catches underneath after you catch the, your string underneath your leg.
So that it's, the yo-yo is hanging underneath your leg,
but you do a series of pop movements and then eventually pop the Bacco
back to a trapeze. You do a series of laceration like elements,
and then landed an amount to return the yo-yo back to your hand.
So a lot of things can go wrong with this trick simply because of the number of
different body parts involved,
the number of different elements and the number of transitions that you have to
make between each of those main components.
So behind the back around the neck and around the leg,
when you're trying to unravel the yo-yo string around the neck,
so that it lands behind your back, Oh, unravel in the wrong direction,
causing you to have a yo-yo just wrapped around your body.
Ultimately the possibility for combinations are endless.
All those tricks that you've seen,
all those levels can be combined in various different ways to create various
combos in a competition. Players will take their own tricks,
take their own combos and create a freestyle routine.
Freestyle yo-yoing is arguably the most difficult because it combines various
elements, tricks, and combinations into a single routine level 26.
Freestyle freestyling is when you just let the universe do its thing,
you do the first string that comes to your mind. And then from that trick,
you transition into the net trick, really,
wherever your hands take you freestyling is about making decisions in the
moment. It's more of an intuition thing where you're just transitioning between
elements, transitioning between mounts, so that you're creating various combos.
As you go. It's a matter of then taking the restricts,
matching districts to music, playing around with the pacing,
playing around with, you know, body elements, playing around with tricks,
which was smaller and technical, and really going with the song.
And the moment sometimes the decisions may lead to a knot.
Sometimes those decisions may lead to a fantastic trick.
It's really about messing around and seeing you at work, seeing what doesn't.
And that's one of the fun parts about yo-yoing because there's so many limitless
possibilities. Thanks, wired.